the introduction of IBM Watson code
assistant IBM hybrid Cloud mesh and IBM
event automation all on this episode of
IBM Tech now what's up y'all my name is
Ian and I am back to bring you the
latest and greatest news and
announcements about IBM technology
if you tuned in last episode you saw me
cover the news out of think around
Watson X and its components but that
wasn't the only news to come out of the
event
on this episode I'm going to cover three
new Innovative products that were also
recently previewed and introduced
setting the stage for an exciting 2023
first up is something that Arvin
previewed in his keynote address IBM
Watson code assistant
Watson code assistant is an Innovative
solution that empowers developers across
all skill levels to write syntactically
correct code with AI generated
recommendations
powered by Watson x.ai Foundation models
Watson code assistant will increase
developer productivity by providing
recommended code based on natural
language inputs
ultimately the aim is to make hybrid
Cloud code development more accessible
and efficient
Watson code assistant is intended to be
generally available later this year it's
designed to reduce the complexity of
coding through these AI generated
content recommendations
additionally organizations will be able
to tune the underlying Foundation model
and customize it with their own
standards
the first available use case for Watson
code assistant will be content
generation for Red Hat ansible
automation platform and you can check
out the link below for more information
next up is IBM hybrid Cloud mesh a new
multi-cloud networking solution that
will be generally available in the
second half of this year
hybrid Cloud mesh is designed to allow
organizations to establish simple and
secured application-centric connectivity
and it's engineered for Network managers
to be able to seamlessly manage and
scale Network applications across public
clouds private clouds Edge and
on-premises
this application first approach is the
next important networking Paradigm it
represents an evolution from the current
fat pipes method which doesn't
differentiate between applications to
one that aligns the network to the needs
of the business users developers and
their CI CD Pipeline and devops Cycles
when it's time to configure new Cloud
networks and connect applications our
approach is designed to turn weeks into
hours and move from manual to automated
processes
to learn more and apply to the Early
Access program of IBM hybrid Cloud mesh
hit the link below
the final announcement I want to cover
today is IBM event automation
every day thousands of business events
flow through your organization that can
provide a wealth of information
IBM event automation is designed to help
you put those events to work by enabling
business and it users to detect
situations in real time act on them and
Trigger automations to help maximize
their revenue potential
this can help your organization become
more responsive to customer needs and
resilient in the face of Shifting market
dynamics
IBM event automation provides an
intuitive and integrated experience that
includes event distribution event
Discovery and event processing it'll be
generally available in late June you can
check out the link below to learn more
thanks so much for joining me today for
this episode of IBM Tech now if you're
interested in learning more about the
topics I've covered make sure you
explore the links in the description of
this video and again please don't forget
to subscribe to our channel to stay up
to date on what's going on in Tech now